welcome back to the omics logic
bioinformatics for precision medicine
program in this video we will be
reviewing what we have learned in
session three the third session on
multiple sequence alignment and
phylogenetic analysis is designed to
build upon the genomic data analysis
skills that you have learned in previous
session
so if you have not gone through the
previous session make sure to complete
the associated coursework and example
projects before proceeding with session
three
to briefly review what we have learned
when we compare multiple genomes from
different samples of patients there are
a couple of questions that comes to our
mind are these genomes different how
different are they which portions of the
genome are more variable which portions
of the genomes are similar to understand
whether genomes are different we can
align them to a reference known as
pairwise alignment or compare multiple
genomes to each other using multiple
sequence alignment
next we learned about percentage
distance or similarity matrix to
quantify the differences in sequences of
sarcop2 and other coronal virus strains
we can generate the similarity or
distance matrix here as we can see in
the image the distance matrix clearly
shows humans are cov2 and the pangolin
coronary virus are more similar whereas
sar cov2 and have nearly 70 to 79
percent similarity with bad coronary
virus
at this point you might be wondering
whether all mutations at nucleotide
level are carried out at amino acid
level or not so here we can take a look
at multiple sequence alignment
representing the differences in the
sequences
at amino acid level
here we can mainly see three things
first there are seven to nine persons
dissimilarity between human sarco v2 and
the pangolin corona virus while 15 to 17
percent dissimilarity is observed
between human psycho2 and the back
corner virus
we can also see that not all variations
at nucleotide level get transferred at
amino acid level as there is a higher
percentage of variations at nucleotide
level than at amino acid level besides
we can also see that similar to the
trend at the nucleotide level variation
sarco v2 is more similar to the pangolin
coronavirus than the bad source and bad
coronavirus
but what can we achieve by comparing the
genomics data of pathogens from patients
we can understand the composition of
viral hypertypes in a given patient
sample
now how do we achieve this we can use a
computational technique known as short
red assembly into haplotypes that is
used to measure genetic diversity among
diverse samples
so far we learned about multiple
sequence alignment next we will learn
how closely related are these genomes
that multiple genomes or whole groups of
genome originate from the same parent
genome or not to find answers to this
question we can perform phylogenetic
analysis to understand the relationship
among them and their origin
here we learnt how analysis of
phylogenetic trees allows for
conclusions to be drawn about epidemic
and pandemic viruses the sequences and
their data can be used to estimate viral
emergence characterize geographic spread
of the virus reconstruct epidemiological
dynamics of viral spread and identify
instances of the adaptation
next we learned about building the
phylogenetic analysis pipeline for
multiple sequence alignment on the
t-biome for server the pipeline
consisted of several steps and each of
these steps are discussed in detail
during the session to summarize we begin
we begin by using start option for
multiple sequence alignment of the
sequences we use three algorithms
multiple sequence alignment for the
nucleotide sequences multiple sequence
alignment a a to incorporate the changes
at the amino acid level and select codon
position multiple sequence alignment to
determine the codon precisions for the
phylogenetic analysis finally we can
generate the phylogenetic tree from
multiple sequence alignment using the
beast speciation work that process
algorithm
afterwards click on the end
button and run the pipeline using a
suitable name
as mentioned in this session the basic
output from the pipeline is a
phylogenetic tree based on multiple
sequence alignment in the dendrogram we
find that the samples are arranged into
two main branches earlier sequences from
the cap on and later samples from
liberia and great britain in the output
file full table dot tsp contains the
details of the sequences that are
aligned at the amino acid level and the
nucleotide level hence the multiple
sequence alignment algorithm gives us
the relation of both these changes
then we discuss some of the key terms
associated with variance such as
variance of interest variance concern
and variance of high consequences and
how these terms differ from each other
we also discussed about the prevalence
of variance contained in the d614g
mutation which has become the wild type
form of sarcasev2 worldwide since mid
2020. we also learned that variants can
become extinct due to natural selection
for instance we discussed about in june
2020 a concerning sarsio v2 variant
thought to present a decreased
sensitivity to the immune response was
detected in mint in the netherlands and
denmark however this variant was
declared extinct just a few months later
and is no longer in circulation
we also discussed about the current
three variants of concern which are
named based on the country from where
they were first identified the alpha
beta and gamma the most concerning is
how these mutations will affect efficacy
of vaccines or protection they offer but
they are also a reflection of how
viruses evolve under different immune
pressures then we discussed about the
increasing prevalence of drug resistant
forms of tuberculosis infection
requiring more effective treatment
strategies here we learned about drug
resistance in turboclasses various
groups of tuberculosis drugs mechanism
of action and genes resistant to these
drugs antibiotics and their mechanisms
of action
the treatment of drug resistant
tuberculosis was more complicated and
can take up to 18 months depending upon
the resistance profile of the infection
as we can see here over the course of 21
years one can observe the changes in the
treatment option that were required to
keep the pathogen under control hence
the variant profiling of the pathogen is
absolutely necessary to manage the
tuberculosis infection
for this we took an example of running
the mutation variant calling pipeline on
the t-bin for server using the mutect2
pipeline what does the algorithm do and
how to interpret the results that also
cover in the session
the contents of session 3 correspond
with practical lessons that you can
complete independently available on the
omixlogic learn portal for this session
we have covered concepts based on
lessons from first 3 genomics the course
serves as an introduction to the
bioinformatics sub-discipline of
genomics where students will be
familiarized with the biology of
genetics and genetic variation while
considering path practical application
within the
course specific lessons that are of the
relevance include lesson 6 phylogenetic
analysis where you will learn about
phylogenetic analysis pipeline building
analysis and biological interpretation
for sarco v2 zoonotic origin
lesson 7 comparing dna sequences using
phylogenetic analysis
will teach you about the generation
about phylogenetic tree from the dna
sequences of samples to understand
evolutionary relationships among them
next we have lesson 8 multiple sequence
alignment visualizing and filtering
alignment here you will learn about how
you can perform and visualize multiple
sequence alignment and filter out the
varying information
the full course contains a lot more
information that you can choose to
explore independently at your own pace
so do not worry about completing all of
them immediately
another great resource that you will
have access to is project 11
surveillance of sar cov2 variance of
concern in this project you will conduct
surveillance of sarco v2 variants of
concern from wastewater samples by
downloading data from the database
perform multiple sequence alignment and
phylogenetic analysis and derive
biological significance and understand
the evolutionary relationship between
samples
another great resource is project 17
tuberculosis infection and treatment
here you will learn to extract data from
big data repositories for patients
infected with mycobacterium tuberculosis
and run pipeline on the t by info
platform to get hands-on experience with
mutation variant calling interpret
biological insights by searching for the
protein variants in the patient's
isolate over 21 years of infection and
look for specific mutations belonging to
each isolate responsible for drug
resistance
in the upcoming session 4 on
transactional data analysis you will
learn what is rna sequencing how do you
prepare your data for rna seq data
analysis how do you carry out biological
implementation of the outputs how is
machine learning used in transatlantic
data analysis and at the end of session
4 you will have a thorough understanding
of transatomic data and be able to carry
out analysis of cancer datasets using
bioinformatic pipelines and various
machine learning techniques